you
[Music]
today I'm gonna talk mostly about some
of the practical lessons that we have
encountered in trying to build this
platform using the advances advancements
in AI a quick background I have been
working in the field of big data and AI
fortunately with some of the best
industry academia leaders mostly in the
applications of behavioral at targeting
recommendation systems you know
click-through rate predictions and
semantic representation of knowledge for
robotics and have been with meltwater
for almost three years now
a brief overview for the folks who don't
know we are a truly global partner in
the space of media intelligence we we
have more than 60 offices across the
world and we sell our product to more
than 30,000 companies globally and we
are you know we are pretty much
bootstrapped with no venture funding in
mid 2000s our core mission ever since we
started our company is you know it's
been almost two decades even though the
type of the data that we have the core
mission is always to enable
forward-looking Nations based on the
insights that we can main mind from
external data traditionally we started
with news this is even before the
concept of social data didn't exist and
over the time we added a lot more data
types like again all the social job
postings are advising right and our our
value thesis is there is a lot of online
breadcrumbs that is out there and if we
systematically mine it there is a lot of
interesting insights that can be found
for decision makers right and you know
examples can be online news to financial
filings web traffic advertising app
downloads trademarks product reviews
consumer confidence etc this is an
ongoing list for us even though we first
started with the news that sawdust for
almost eight years before we had to add
any other data type but now our most of
our innovation is in terms of
trying to add more data type and trying
to extract knowledge from it so
outside/inside is the sort of the
tagline for our company
so we leverage AI and ML technologies to
derive insights from all the external
data this is sort of the different
offerings that we have everything from
cadence reports to responses to the
media like crisis management to
real-time alerting on the events and
predictive signals that help us
understand the growth and risk of a
company or a brand who is being used I
mean you know there are several personas
as we call it we have customers who are
actual investors inverse relations
corporate strategy PR corporate
communications marketing product
development teams and sales leaders all
of them are built on top of the same
platform they get a slightly different
view based on the workflow they are
trying to optimize for yeah as like our
CEO would like to call it we have
customers from Pope to cook leveraging
your product in some or other fashion
yeah why do we need AI why do we need AI
to make sense of the external data right
as most of you know the external data is
very unstructured so we need a lot of
data mining techniques to you know
structure it and also find some
interesting patterns it mostly comes in
the form of text that's the that's the
medium that we are going after from
external data perspective so we need a
ton of natural language processing
techniques it comes in many languages
and lemony shapes right like for example
news is a long-form document it - it can
be a very short form patent is well much
more structured with technical terms it
comes in lot of shapes so we need a way
to do domain adaptation and also you
know we have a crop more than like 80
languages in terms of the data that we
bring in and we cannot build a model
from scratch for each and everything the
data can be very deceitful you guys know
this it's a there is a lot of
contradictory data or wrong data that is
out there so we need a way to extract
this knowledge in a very
actual way we need to assign confidence
to everything that we mind it can be
really difficult to connect the dots if
we just provide monitoring its you will
just understand what has happened but if
you really want to turn it into a signal
we need to connect the dots across the
different data types and insights that
we are building so we need some form of
machine learning and reasoning as part
of the platform it does contain a lot of
forward-looking indicators so it's about
systematically mining it so we need to
inability to run predictive algorithms
on top of the platform and of course
it's it's a very very large data we have
more than one point three trillion
documents in our corpus and we are
adding like around 700 million documents
every day it is a very large data and we
need our our or compute and storage
needs to be distributed over the time
through the challenges that we have
faced we assembled a scientific advisory
board who excel in the areas of web data
extraction knowledge graph processing
NLP and information extraction domain
adaptation and information network
analysis they have really helped us in
understanding what is the right way to
define several interfaces for the
platform for our machine learning
engineers to be more effective not just
internally but also external people who
use our platform so today I'm going to
mostly talk about fairhair AI that's
what we refer to as as the or underlying
platform that powers all the products
across all the buying centers that you
have seen and it's a it's a complete
data platform with a lot of AI models in
it
and a lot of tooling for data scientists
to really accelerate in terms of
insights creation it's pretty powerful
you know it's really powering more than
30 thousand business customers who's
using it and it is arranged into a lot
of data enrichment services and inside
services and at the heart of everything
is knowledge graph which is essentially
what I'm going to cover in most of this
talk so what is a knowledge graph right
I mean if you just google for knowledge
graph there are so many definitions
because it's a very loosely used term
you know you have anthologies you have
knowledge bases
knowledge graphs I mean Google sort of
refers knowledge graph as their
underlying common-sense factual
knowledge that really powers their
search engine some people refer to
knowledge graphs as a large network of
entities with semantic types and
properties
some people say knowledge graph is
mainly to describe real world entities
organized as form of a graph and this is
like a survey that was done by some
university because this concept
knowledge graph is coming up again and
again but I would like to first explain
what we define as knowledge graph as
butter for platform so that it sets a
right precedence through the rest of the
talk so yeah let us say we have a lot of
different data that we bring in right we
get company websites all the news blocks
press releases forums all the social
data from all the firehoses
job postings public filings and if we
have a lot more it's one to show an
example so we index all the data around
key entities and for us key entities are
organizations people products brands
right so those are the key entities that
we essentially structure all our data we
extract entities attributes
relationships events trends some
bare-minimum
analytics that gives us some basic
understanding of what's happening around
these entities and predictions over time
and we also connect them so that we have
an easy way to start reasoning around
the analytics that we are building on
top of the platform so we have a ton of
cert tools and services that helps us
discover cannot understand and deliver
the insights that are being that are
being driven from lot of data types that
we have one might ask what's the
importance of organizing as a knowledge
gap I kinda just put all of this inside
a massive search engine and call it the
day which we did for a long time you
know we we were running I believe like
fourth or fifth biggest elasticsearch
cluster in the world indexing 1.2
trillion documents but it was
considerably getting harder when
want to provide more than vanilla
analytics if you really want to start
reasoning the insights if you want to
start doing causality correlations right
really trying to explain why event has
occurred and how it is relevant to the
work for us that they have done we need
to start having reasoning capabilities
right so initially we started with just
you know trying to focus on indexing a
lot of data and over the time we started
trying to get a semantic understanding
of how the data is organized and because
of that you know we have a lot of
interesting applications of or layers
that are built in the platform now like
recommendation engines contextual search
semantic searchers inference engines and
that has really helped the api's on top
of the platform for the applications to
be more intelligent and this is
essentially how the entire layer AI is
that the underlying thesis is it covers
the whole AI lifecycle and is completely
centered around the knowledge graph but
the particular thing is we are not an
open domain knowledge graph like how
Google defines it we are around a closed
domain around companies and it's related
entities so this is essentially
different parts I'm going to quickly go
over each of them through the rest of
the presentation it starts with a lot of
outside data and their investments in
trying to do web data extraction on
onthe more than 10 million sources I'm
going to cover about or NLP stack
everything gets dumped into our data
platform and we create a knowledge graph
and we have layers for doing graph
embedding graph aggregation graph
convolution and reasoning entrance right
and this hybrid inference is essentially
where we are generating a lot of
insights from that align data so the
platform is not only used by all our
products but it's also heavily used at
top universities currently these are the
active projects that are going on across
Stanford Carnegie Mellon and Oxford who
are building
a pretty long-term I know look four to
five-year long-term projects on top of
the platform my favorite ones are
question answering graph rule mining any
resolution and the fakeness reduction is
one of the social costs kind of a
European funded project where they're
trying to understand how to detect the
fact of a news not just based on what's
being reported but based on how it is
connected to the rest of the facts that
are being generated from other news that
are out there and these partnerships
have really helped us in understanding
what are the right interfaces for us to
build the platform over time through
different layers right so let me first
start with the data you know we are in a
way world's largest corpus of outside
data around the entities that we care
about at this point I think at the
minute we have like more than 1.3
trillion documents from millions of
sources spanning 80 different languages
and we have data of three types one is
compliance term compliant data these are
like Twitter firehoses
right which are not generally available
for you to scrape from the internet but
something that we get through
partnerships we have hundreds of
partnerships that are delivering data to
us to be analyzed then we have the data
from open web which is where we use some
AI technologies to really automate the
induction of the wrappers which I'm
going to go over and the third is
companies also push their own data to
augment the external data to derive
insights around the company when we talk
about data from open web right and when
we want to capture knowledge information
there are different places where we can
get data from you know we can do web
data extraction from Dom's mostly from
temporary websites from annotations this
is a site Micro data that are filled by
humans we have a lot of web tables where
there is a lot of interesting
information and from all the text that
we capture we can do information
extraction to to get some interesting
knowledge I'm gonna first talk about the
web bread extraction and this is
typically what I call as academic web
right
the typical comments that you hear are
hey we have a lot of microdata we have
semantic web that has solved this
problem we don't need any intelligent
scrapers most of the data is nicely
programmatically available right so I
have like a nice temporary website with
a pretty house here but in real world
it's it's really bad you know the api's
are very limited to large web sites and
web tables and my credit is very
marginal in terms of the information new
information that you can find and the
real problem is not in terms of the
one-time extraction but keeping the data
up-to-date so there's a so-called
knowledge graph that I spoke about it's
it's temporal in nature
it's the difference in the information
sets that we get is essentially what
gives us the insights I mean the static
snapshot is more like a question
answering engine to get a sense of
what's happening now but really to
really understand what has changed over
time you need this temporality aspect
and that's essentially where we find key
or key sort of predictive signals that
we can come up with so far as continuous
extraction is is is not just a
requirement but it's very much necessary
for us for most of our insights and
traditional scraping right I guess you
guys know this usually you write code
wrappers for for sources these are like
XPath expressions that basically tells
you you know what part of the website is
what particular field right at some
point in the time in the in the past we
were basically writing these expert code
wrappers we had more than 50 source
engineers who are maintaining these
manual wrappers but the problem is the
sources were failing the check they
changed all the time and it really it
really gets unmanageable to manage the
sources and then we of course we also
experimented with visual support tools
so that you don't really have to you
don't really have to really code it up
but you can actually build visual tools
to generate the wrappers but the still
the underlying problem is the source has
changed all the time it's really hard to
keep up so the the method that we went
after is basically automatic generation
which is what we call as wrapper
induction to generate the
rappers that actually go out and fetch a
given completed website but the problem
is you know as I mentioned initially we
start with news that's mostly like a few
hundred thousand new sources over the
time when we added more and more data
there are types now we have more than 10
million sources we really need to scale
to the web in terms of doing induction
but what we can effort is a bit of a
prior knowledge about a given site right
for example if you are trying to extract
addresses from a corporate website from
the knowledge graph you essentially know
for all the previous addresses that you
have seen how the address is laid out
like you know you have the street number
followed by street name followed by city
in u.s.
whereas in UK it's probably you have
what the block number followed by the
actual code followed by the street so
there is a bit of a domain knowledge
that you can actually capture based on
the information that you know about
entities already and these are mostly
expressed as gazetteers or rules and and
also we want to generate and we can't
generate a wrapper from ground up all
the time right so what we did was we
built a framework for rule-based feature
engineering that essentially supports
quick turnaround time and it captures
some domain-specific rich features right
and these features are representing the
structure of the site the visual
rendering textual content link structure
interface patterns so you have a base
library of 2500 features that we have
built and for each of the domain you
need a special customization in order to
tweak it for a for a for a new area and
of course we do continuous exploration
form understanding and filling record
attribution and induction before we go
actually go into the extraction of the
web page this has been a long work we
started in early 2010 and we published
over all the different components that
essentially go into most of the web data
extraction conferences right these are
solid work
that took us a long time to get to the
place where we can automatically apply
wrappers now and the effects are you
know we we spend 90% less human human
effort in maintaining most of our
external facial systems and we are able
to extract what more attributes than
before simply because these are
programmatically configured rather than
a human configuring those and we explore
at our sources from almost 300,000 new
sources to 10 million sources in a span
of two years and to get from zero to 300
it took us almost 15 years so in the new
frontier we are doing now so-called
browser less extraction so we spoke
about how we are generating this
wrappers but these wrappers are still
poor visual wrappers so that you you
fire up a browser and you execute the
wrapper the problem is some sites
actually produce so much content
especially Chinese sources we are not
able to keep up with keeping the lid
keeping our SLS in our system so now we
started exploring what called HTTP api
wrappers where we essentially try to
understand so the way it was started was
we started actually doing json crawling
which is just looking at the backend API
so what the website is calling and
trying to replicate the program right so
this is not like a visual wrapper you
write those programs and these programs
are something that humans like regular
source engineers cannot write it
requires like software engineering
engine credit so we started looking at
okay can we look at how the browser is
rendering the calls its making
looking at the trace graph and trying to
understand what are the underlying API
calls its making that we can fetch the
data automatically right we made some
good strides in that we published a
paper in the doubled-up conference this
year and there is a and what we have
seen is between the Oh X path that's our
language for expat and the history of
rewrappers you can see that for a
variety of datasets where we benchmarked
we see that the number of interactions
that are needed to get the full content
has substantial reduce like 90
interactions to one enough interactions
because you are essentially fishing for
the underlying API call very promising
but I want to say that this is not fully
shaniyah this is the next frontier on
where we are going after and of course
we also do a lots of fetching from fire
roses as I said you know mob in that
seven hundred million more than half of
it comes from fire hoses of data right
through different partnerships that we
have and we built our own sort of
incision data mapping language so that
it's really easy to on board the sources
and this language is actually you don't
have to be a programmer to write the
mapping language into our system we open
source and it's also very heavily used
in a lot of other companies it's mostly
to do like simple et else and convert
from one format to another right and we
also wrote a lot of tooling around
multiplexing across different queues and
this is so that we can bridge various
data processing queues that happen over
time and we support a lot of data
sources in terms of sources and sinks in
fact this was so heavily used that at
some point we were actually trending so
this was a key engineer who wrote the
who wrote this tool benthos and for a
long time we were actually like the
second most popular git repository in
the in the in the in the trending just
quite cool to see a lot of outside
adaption on a very simple problem of if
I have something like two different
queues
I have Khafre and I have rabbit and I
need to shovel the data from one to
another right and it turns out when you
actually try to do a lot of data
integration you have to integrate with
lots of queues so it's a pretty dumb
multiplexer but it's it's something that
people started using a lot which we are
very proud of so after the data you know
that's essentially how we do a bit
extraction and we built a lot of
proprietary enrichment services for all
the textual data that we bring in right
and the goal is we want to bring the
data very close to the models right
before the explosion of some of these
deep pre-trained models we had to build
models that are very specific to news
very specific to tweets very specific to
reviews because they come in different
shapes we were doing order domain
adapter
and in order to scale across the zero
types and languages so typically what we
try to do is you know we do integer
cognition right and resolution event
extraction relation extraction sentiment
over especially if it is things like
news reviews social documents a lot of
topic categorization right resolution of
links I'm gonna go over some of this
methods where we especially especially
tried and productionize some of the
neural architectures isn't recently so
these essentially are all sort of
different NLP tasks that we do in our
company and we did a benchmark across
different providers that are out there
both in terms of the cloud providers and
also like on Prem providers right the
one of the main reasons we built our own
is there is no one no one partner that
is fully comprehensive in terms of what
we need both in terms of language
coverage and the type of task that we
want to go after we want to keep the
costs in control of course and the
biggest thing is it was really hard to
customize the models when we're relying
on most of the external partners right
so these are like pre-trained models but
it's really hard to do adaptation based
on that because you don't you cannot
really introspect into those we are
scaling all these enrichments to almost
seven hundred million documents on a
daily basis so some so at some points we
actually took some trade-offs in terms
of the quality of the model to the
performance but at the same time you
also have the deeper models if you want
to apply this on on a subset stream of
for data that is flowing through a
platform so few of the so few of the NLP
enrichments that I would like to go
after and today's stuff are at the
entity recognition resolution and the
relation extraction right like for
example this is mainly to populate our
knowledge graph that's the integral
mission is so that whenever we see a
piece of text we can essentially
recognize the spans of the text that our
entities of interest to us so we mainly
go after organization products people's
breath
the task of any D which is named entry
disambiguation is to resolve the surface
form that we that we got as an entity to
our underlying knowledge graph for
example if you say Tesla but the Tesla
can be Tesla Science Center
Tesla Inc or a Czechoslovakian company
called Tesla we need to understand which
Tesla this particular Tesla belongs to
right and the last one is we do relation
extraction right this is in this case we
want to have a age in our graph or a
fact you know graph that says that Tesla
has acquired the SolarCity right or has
announced full acquisition of SolarCity
so that recorded as relation extraction
in terms of the any architecture we do
we have two models one is based on the
traditional CRF models where we use the
basics like the post tags Brown clusters
non chunks and throw it into a CRF model
we were actually doing quite good in
terms of the f1 right and then we
started experimenting with character
level embeddings so we we we embed we do
like word level vectors and the
character embeddings and it through a
bi-directional STM and then we apply a
CRF on top of it so even though we
didn't really see a lot of improvement
of a CRF vs LST MCN and CRF the place
where it was useful to support still
this new Olympic architecture models is
for domain adaptation right in case the
traditional CRF if you want to move from
one language to another or to move from
news to a social document it needed a
ground-up reor a ground-up building of
the model whereas in most of this word
and character level embeddings we are
able to train some more retrain some of
the higher layer layer higher network
layers and we saw some interesting
variable to at least bootstrap the
models with with acceptable f1 scores in
other languages and there are types very
easily but when it comes to
disambiguation
what we do is we represent our
knowledge graph in a dbpedia like schema
which is extended and it gets converted
into a leucine index right and we use an
algorithm called egg justice which is
essentially like a PageRank walk on the
on the graph and when you see the
surface form right like the entities
that you see in a text what we do is we
get candidates from the graph under line
graph and then look at other entities
that are existing and other terms that
are existing and use that as contextual
features to sort of do a graph walk to
get the actual true doodoo probability
assignment of what entity that
particular surface form is talking about
right so in that example the entities
like Tesla solar city right they gets
resolved to the Tesla Inc and the solar
city Inc in serigraph you know we have
more debt but but the problem here we
started seeing some problems here for
bigger companies where there is a lot of
information about it right or a lot of
entities known entities that are
associated with it it's easier to do
resolving like things like Tesla it's
probably easier simply because there's a
lot of information about Tesla that you
can mine a lot of known structure
entities like you know maybe you on musk
or or other batteries right there are a
lot of pre-existing dbpedia concepts or
Wikipedia concepts around Tesla but if
you look at long tail companies there is
not much structural information that we
can find about them so just way by using
who the founders are or what the product
does it's not enough sufficient
information to resolve those entities
from the documents so what we did was we
essentially built like a term minor
right that essentially mines firm for
discriminative terms based on all the
occurrences of the of the smaller
companies in any of the data types that
we have seen and trying to sort of
populate the graph with these contextual
words that are necessary to do the work
so in a way we are trying to populate
the graph with a lot of significant
discriminative terms which might or
might not be entities right but still
help us in resolving
smaller companies and but the problem is
most of the most of this work has been
done only on English so far and since we
rely on the underlying dbpedia indexes
we can actually go from one language to
another by doing the walks across those
language bindings right or the index
bindings that we have next is the
relation extraction again the task is
here to predict the class of a semantic
relation between pairs of entities that
we see in a text we did we did work
around trying to you know using word
embeddings positional embeddings we saw
some interesting results around around
certain relation types like for example
yeah so this is actually the network
architecture so we use the attention
based by lsdm it's a reimplementation of
a paper that was published but it's just
we productionize dit and apply it at a
very very large scale the good the thing
to note here is these are these offense
scores that are noted like some of them
are really bad right
like point three seven point six five
that's mostly because of unavailability
of enough amount of training data with
the labels that says that okay this
document is expressed in this relation
but luckily given that we don't look at
a date their document in isolation we
try to actually look at the facts
derived from a lot of documents to start
getting the real confidences in the
graph so we even even though even though
so but the thing is pair document NLP
extraction can only take you a take your
jakie certain way we also do a lot of
event extraction in the interest of the
time I'm going to skip it but these are
things like acquisitions product
launches right we have a large ontology
of hundreds of even types that we we
extract we wear which is mostly we use
like writing rules like semantic rules
on top of the NLP tasks output in the
interest of time I'm gonna skip over
our deeper sentiment model
right we do something called as a
character level sentiment analysis where
we can actually see over the time how
the sentiment has said Wendy's behave
behaved within a text and then we
overlay it with entities and aspects we
we have our own sort of studio for
creating training data set that has
adapters to the rafters to Google and
Amazon for building around custom models
we have very sophisticated pipeline
infrastructure to run this NOP which
reports it suppose things like
conditional Forks and joins a way to
actually dynamically score the models
goldset creations and we built our
infrastructure hosted pipelines this is
something that our NLP developers can
easily configure with the JSON where
they can talk where they can essentially
configure pipelines and deploy it in
production either with with a simple
JSON file which is really interesting
because we don't like most of the data
scientists the they would like to spend
more time on the building of the models
and less on the infrastructure problem
that is needed so the more you faster
enable this the better it is in the new
frontiers of NLP we did a lot of work by
using the shallow pre-training models
like what effects and gloves we are
excited to see that there has been a lot
more deeper pre-trained models that not
only that can actually capture the
meaning of the word the syntax and the
semantics of the world like Elmo you
alum fit opening I transformers the
recent release Google but these are like
real I mean I call it like the image net
error for NLP right this is really
helping us in in in in actually
replacing the lower-level embeddings and
and representing higher-level features
for most common a little bit tasks so
there's a lot that we can do with it so
out of all the sources that we get when
we get from web and when we get from
text right we get several sources of
knowledge and we need to assemble this
into a graph typical problems are when
we get objects from multiple sources how
do we know whether they're referring to
the same real world entities
in one so sauce it might say it's Intel
in the other source it says Intel
Corporation and third might say Intel
Corp right so our recording workflow
it's a yeah it's a usual technique we
use group agglomerative clustering to
actually improve the thresholds we also
do truth discovery this is so that we
can actually aggregate on the
conflicting data sources like if I give
you a table how would you say where does
Spotify belong right the simple thing is
you can do majority voting but the
problem is what happens if you have ties
and how do you trust a social liability
so what we do is we iteratively compute
the truth of the fact that is that is
derived from a source and based on the
facts and also compute the reputation of
the source and you recursively go over
the graph all the time to start
assigning confluences finally when you
assemble all the graphs like how do you
enforce ontological rules for that we
have a paper and ICD called rule mining
where we try to understand what are the
most common patterns of rules that
violate the rest of the ontology right
it goes through human feedback but this
essentially how we keep the how we keep
the knowledge graph clean we can't talk
about text analytics without talking
about the the search and the backend we
have we invest a lot of elastic search
over time this is mainly used for our
serving layer and then we have a ton of
other additional inferences to do
reasoning convolution the hybrid
inference rule mining right yeah I can
skip this we did a lot of work in trying
to run the fourth biggest elasticsearch
cluster to make sure that we do optimal
chart place for in Ecuador thing we have
some interesting blog posts in that
warrant who are curious you can skip
this weekend yeah most of this work done
has been published that's something that
something can be referred yeah in the
interest of time I had to accelerate the
last several slides but I'm happy to
take any questions either here or in the
office hours later thank you
you
[Applause]
[Music]